like you said no new Wars this makes me
think if uh Donald Trump won the
presidency what the the current
situation in Ukraine would look like but
let me just ask you zoom out and ask you
broadly um do you think the war in
Ukraine could have been avoided and what
do you think it takes to bring it to an
end I think 100% it would have been
avoided not 99% you know president Trump
for uh four years had no problems with
Russia you know we were we were arming
Ukraine but we were working with Russia
and again the first two years we had a
little bit of issue working with Russia
because they were accused of colluding
with us and we had to go through that
investigation but um but in the second
two years we were trying to focus Russia
on what are the areas where we can
collaborate together I think Russia you
know we thought it was in their
strategic advantage to play uh us and
China against each other because of the
way that everything was done before they
were stuck with China but not getting a
lot for it um under Bush they took
Georgia under Obama they took Crimea
under Trump there was no problems and
then under Biden U unfortunately I think
they misplayed a couple of things uh
which I think provoked uh you know
Russia to to go forward um still no
excuse to do what they did I think that
the invasion was a terrible thing and
and should not have occurred um but with
that being said um I think 100% if Trump
was President there would not be a war
in Ukraine today coming to the table and
negotiating a
piece whether it's Donald Trump whether
it's Biden whether it's anybody what do
you think it takes uh do you think it's
possible uh and if you're in a room if
Jer kushna is in the room Vladimir Putin
and Vladimir zalinski what does it take
to have a productive conversation and
what does it take for that conversation
to fail like what are the trajectories
that lead to success and failure I think
we go back to negotiations number one is
trust right both leaders have to have
the ability to
communicate what an offramp is without
fearing it's going to leak to the public
so if you go to the posture of zalinsky
right now and by the way president
zalinsky I have a lot of respect for the
courage he showed uh especially
initially um you know you saw what gani
did in Afghanistan they they were
getting attacked by the Taliban he took
the cash and got the hell out of there
staying in Kiev when he did how he did
it was one of the most Brave things
we've seen in a long time uh and he has
a ton of my respect and admiration for
doing that but now he's promising his
people we're going to win the war and
the military action has not necessarily
coincided with that sentiment and so
there has to be some form of of off-ramp
but he can't say that publicly so for
him to be able to work privately with
somebody who can help create a new
paradigm where both leaders can say
we're going to stop the bloodshed we're
going to stop the risk of nuclear war
for the world we're going to stop um
what's
happening that's really what it will
take how that occurs again it's not
something I'm involved in now so I don't
know who the right broker is or how to
put that together but essentially they
need somebody in between them who can
figure out how do you create a landing
Zone that that works because neither
part is going to jump until the pool is
filled with water and you have to
outline what the go forward looks like
because you can't just stop it for then
it to get worse for both parties you
have to you have to move it forward into
what happens next that hopefully can
start to turn the tide to benefit both
sides where they can focus on the future
instead of being stuck into the old
Paradigm of who started what who's to
blame for what who did what to who it's
just a lot of tough stuff now that
that's occurred that's going to be hard
to walk back and um it's a big task to
get it done but for the sake of the
world it'd be amazing if we were able to
reach a conclusion to that conflict just
going back to the your earlier mention
of North
Korea what do you think it takes to
bring Vladimir Putin and Vladimir
zalinsky to the table together
leadership so you you you're saying like
it has to be a US
president it has to be somebody who's
willing to put themsel on the line yeah
to go and do it and you know again if
you're US president and you're the most
powerful nation in the world you should
be trying yeah but I do think again the
posture that the US has taken is
probably been in a place where they it
would be very hard for them to get the
trust of Russia based on the way that
they've played their moves to date you
know I always thought from the beginning
that Putin would try to bring in
president X and China to resolve it to
basically give a big screw you to
America to say you know China's now the
one you know in charge of this but that
that hasn't seemed to manifest itself to
date either but it takes leadership you
know the leaders have to get it and say
you know let's get everyone together and
let's try to get this done because every
day it goes on a more people are dying
um and B you know we do risk nuclear war
for the world which is not a good
situation